สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนวันนี้เรามา
เจอกันวันอะไรคะครูฟ้าวันนี้เรามาเจอกัน
วันพุธค่ะ
วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 26
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
ตุลาคม
กำลัง
คิดอยู่
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้
กี่โมงแล้วคะ
ตอนนี้เวลา
14:00 น
กลับมาพบกับครูฟ้ากับครูเรียมอีกแล้วนะคะ
ในเวลาบ่าย 2 โมง 6 นาทีและ
คลาสใช่ไหมคะอันนี้มี 4
เล่นเกมหรือเปล่าคะวันนี้
เล่นเกมหรอคะ
ไม่ดีกว่าค่ะไม่ดีกว่าไม่อยากเล่นเกมเลย
เพราะว่าเวลาบ่ายสองเนี่ยนะคะครูเรียมมัน
เป็นเวลาที่เรากินข้าวแล้วใช่ไหมคะกิน
ข้าวแล้วเตรียมกินข้าวแล้วใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะ
เตรียมกินข้าวแล้วครูฟ้ากินข้าวหรือยังคะ
ครูฟ้ากินข้าวแล้วค่ะกินข้าวเสร็จแล้ว
อิ่มมาก
กินสปาเก็ตตี้กินไก่กินไส้กรอกกินเป๊ปซี่
กินกินอะไรอิ่ม
ใช่ไหม
อ่ะ
ไม่มีค่ะครูเรียม
กินเยอะๆนะกินเข้าไปเยอะๆ
ก็จะ
[เพลง]
ง่วงนอนมากเลยค่ะตอนนี้
เราพร้อมนอนแล้วค่ะและเวลานอนเนี่ยเราก็
ต้องฟังใช่ไหมคะนักเรียนตั้งแต่เด็กๆเนาะ
ฟังอะไรดีล่ะ
ฟัง
เพลง
ฟังนิทานใช่ไหม
ใช่
ค่ะซึ่งไม่ฟังเพลงเพราะครูฟ้าไม่ได้มา
ร้องเพลงให้ฟังนะวันนี้ก็เลยเอาเป็นฟัง
นิทานละกันถ้าครูฟ้าร้องเพลงอาจจะแบบนอน
ไม่หลับนอนไม่หลับ
ก็เลยเอานิทานมาเล่าให้ฟังแทน
นิทานเหมือนเดิมค่ะนักเรียนแต่ไม่ใช่
นิทานเรื่องเดิมนะคะนิทานเหมือนเดิมก็คือ
ครูฟ้าเล่านิทานทุกอาทิตย์แต่เปลี่ยนไม่
ผ่านใช่ไหมเปลี่ยนเรื่องไปเรื่อยๆวันนี้
เนี่ยก็มีนิทานมาเล่าให้นักเรียนฟัง
เหมือนกันนะคะชื่อเรื่อง
ห่านกับไข่ทองคำ
[เพลง]
ที่เป็นสัตว์
ไข่ทองคำค่ะกูก็ขอแชร์สกรีนนะคะได้เลยค่ะ
นักเรียนคิดว่าแชร์ได้เลย
ห่านคืออะไร
เราจะวาดหางมาดูกันนะคะว่านักเรียนจะรู้
ไหมว่าครูแปลว่าทหาร
นะ
คะ
[เพลง]
อันนี้คือคอใช่ไหม
ยาวมากๆใช่ไหมคะคือเหลี่ยม
ใช่ค่ะ
ถ้าเกิดคอสั้นก็จะเหมือนเป็ดนะ
งั้นเดี๋ยววาดคอใหม่นะคะนักเรียนห่าน
เนี่ยคอยาวค่ะเพราะฉะนั้น
[เพลง]
เหมือนหรือเปล่าไม่รู้นะคะแต่ว่ามีปีก
ด้วยปีก
ครูฟ้าวาดแล้ว
เตรียมลืมหั่นไปเลย
เปิดดูในโทรศัพท์
ห่านกับเป็ดไม่เหมือนกัน
ไม่เหมือนกัน
เนื้อหา
ให้นักเรียนดูนะคะ
ห่านกับเป็ด
ขอบคุณครูฟ้าค่ะที่วาดให้เราดู
[เพลง]
เป็นไหม
ได้อีกเลย
นะคะผ่านเนี่ยน่ากลัวกว่าเป็ดนะคะนัก
เรียน
อันนี้ห่าน
นะ
กลัวมากกว่านะคะน่ากลัวมากกว่าเรียมเคย
เห็นแบบห่านวิ่งๆ
แล้วก็วิ่งไล่กัดคน
น่ากลัวนะคะ
นักเรียนไม่เหมือนกัน
ฉันกลับมาที่หาดน้องภูฟ้านะคะ
ผ่านที่หน้าตา
จำได้แล้วค่ะครูฟ้าขอบคุณค่ะ
[เพลง]
จริงๆนักเรียนปาก
ห่านกับไข่ทองคำ
1 ตัวค่ะและไข่ไข่เนี่ยไม่ใช่ไข่ธรรมดา
ใช่ไหมนักเรียน
ไข่นะคะมันเป็นไข่ทองคำ
นี่ไม่ใช่พระอาทิตย์นะคะไม่ใช่
นะคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
มีทองคำไม่ใช่ไข่ธรรมดานะคะ
เอาไปขายแล้วก็จะได้เงินเยอะๆ
ใช่ค่ะมันเอาไปเปลี่ยนเป็นเงินได้ใช่ไหม
[เพลง]
ใช่ไหมได้เงินแบบเยอะๆเลยนะคะเพราะว่า
เป็นไข่ทองคำก็เปลี่ยนเป็นเงินได้
เรื่องนี้ก็จบแล้วใช่ไหมคะรู้ป่ะ
มีห่านกับไข่ทองคำไงทองคำค่ะยังไม่จบค่ะ
ยังไม่ได้เริ่มเลยอันนี้คือชื่อเรื่องนะ
คะชื่อเรื่องห่านกับไข่ทองคำ
แล้วเกิดอะไรขึ้นกับห่าน
และเกิดอะไรขึ้นกับไข่ทองคำค่ะ
ทองคำนะคะเรื่องนี้เนี่ยก็จะมีผู้ชายคน
นึงค่ะ
ก็เป็นเขาเรียกว่าเป็นคนไม่มีเงินเป็นคน
จนนั่นแหละใช่ไหมผู้ชาย 1 คน
อายุน่าจะประมาณ
อายุ 68
ผู้ชายคนนี้ทำงานไหมคะ
ไม่ได้ทำงานอะไรเลยค่ะครูเรียมไม่มีเงิน
ผู้ชายไม่มีเงินเราบอกว่าเป็นคนจนนะคะ
ไม่มีเงินเลยผู้ชายคนนี้มีอย่างเดียวก็
คือบ้าน
[เพลง]
มีบ้าน
แล้วผู้ชายคนนี้อยู่
ที่บ้านคนเดียวหรอคะใช่ค่ะแค่คนเดียวเท่า
นั้นผู้ชายคนนี้อยู่บ้านนี้นะคะ
คนเดียวกับห่าน
1 ตัว
นะคะอยู่กันแบบนี้แหละ
ห่านกับผู้ชายห่าน 1 ตัวแล้วก็คนหนึ่งคน
เท่านั้นนะคะก็
อายุ 68 แล้วไม่มีเงินไม่มีเงินเลยมีแค่
บ้านเท่านั้น
บ้านเก่าๆด้วยนะเป็นบ้านเก่าๆค่ะซึ่ง
30  40 ปีผ่านไปแล้วบ้านหลังหนึ่งบ้าน
หลังนี้เนี่ยอายุประมาณ
39 แล้วกัน 30  40
[เพลง]
เป็นบ้านเล็กๆแบบคนจนใช่ไหมบ้านของคนจนนะ
ซึ่ง
แม่ห่านก็จะมีไข่วันละ 1 ฟอง
ไข่วันละ 1 ฟองเท่านั้นนะคะ 1 วันก็จะมี
ไข่ 1 ฟอง
ให้ผู้ชายคนนี้เอาไข่เนี่ยไปขายที่ตลาด
[เพลง]
เอาไปขายได้เงินน้อยมาก
นิดเดียวนะคะผู้ชายคนนี้ก็เลยจน
ไม่มีอะไรเลยทุกวันทุกวันเนี่ยมีแค่ไข่ 1
ฟองเท่านั้นเป็นไข่ธรรมดา
แล้วไม่อ่านเนี่ยเห็นผู้ชายคนนี้ไม่มี
เงินใช่ไหมหารก็เลยคิดเออ
ทำยังไงดีเพราะผู้ชายคนนี้ก็ดูแลห่าน
มีข้าวให้กินมีน้ำให้กิน
ถึงเขาจะไม่มีเงินแต่เขาก็ดูแลห่าน
มีอาหารให้ตลอดเวลาใช่ไหม
ไม่อ่านก็เลยคิดว่า
ถ้าอย่างนั้น
แม่ห่านเนี่ย
จะออกไข่เป็นไข่ทองคำออกมาค่ะ
[เพลง]
ผ่านเลือกได้หรอคะ
เดี๋ยว
ออกไข่เป็นไข่ทองคำนะเนี่ยออกมา
[เพลง]
บอกว่าเป็นการตอบแทนที่ผู้ชายใช่ไหมผู้
ชายช่วยเลี้ยงแม่หาดหมาให้อาหารกินให้
อะไรกินนะคะก็เลยออกไข่ทองคำนี่เลยเป็น
ไข่ทองคำมา
1  2
ผู้ชายเห็นแล้วดีใจไหมคะ
ผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ยเห็นไข่ทองคำก็ดีใจมากๆ
ค่ะครูเรียมอุ้ยทำไมมีไข่ทองคำด้วย
ไข่มันเป็นสีเหลืองหรือเปล่าสีเหลือง
ใช่ค่ะ
ผู้ชายคนนี้ก็เลยหยิบไข่ทองคำแล้วก็รีบ
เอาไข่
ไปขาย
เอาไข่เนี่ยไปขายก็เลยได้เงินมา
เยอะมากนะคะได้เงินมาเยอะ
ๆเยอะมากๆเลยผู้ชายคนนี้ก็เลยมีเงินมี
เงินมีเงินมีเงินมากขึ้นเรื่อยๆนะคะ
และเวลาที่คนเราแบบมีเงินมีเงินมีเงินมี
เงินมากๆก็จะกลายเป็นคนรวย
ใช่ค่ะ
แล้วดีจังเลย
ห่านจะได้สบายไง
ห่านดีจังได้แล้วมีข้าวกินมีน้ำกินมีความ
ใช่แล้วแต่ห่านตัวนี้เนี่ยจะออกไข่ทองคำ
ได้แค่วันละ 1 ใบเท่านั้นใครจะได้แค่วัน
ละ 1 นะคะ 1  2 ไม่ได้ 3 ไม่ได้ 4 ไม่ได้
1 วันก็คือ
1 ฟองหนึ่งใบขายเขาเรียกเป็นอะไรเป็น
ฟอง
1 ใบ
ก็นั่นแหละได้แค่วันละ 1 ฟองนะคะผู้ชายคน
นี้ก็คิด
ทำไมห่าน
ออกไข่ได้แค่วันละ 1
อยากได้เงินอีกอ่ะ
1 วันเนี่ยขายไข่ทองคำ
1 ฟองได้เงินก็โอเคก็ได้เงินโอเคแหละแต่
ว่า
อยากได้มากขึ้นอยากได้เงินเนี่ยนะคะมาก
ขึ้น
ทำยังไงดีอ่ะครูฟ้า
ก็ซื้อห่านมาได้ไหมซื้อห่านมาอีกตัวนึง
แต่มันไม่ใช่ห่านไม่รู้เราก็ไม่รู้ใช่ไหม
ว่าห่านที่ซื้อมาเนี่ยจะออกไข่เป็นไข่ทอง
คำหรือเปล่า
ผู้ชายคนนี้นะคะก็เลยคิดว่า
ห่านตัวนี้
ในท้องของห่านตัวนี้ในท้องเนี่ย
อันนี้ปีกนะคะ
แต่ว่าหมายถึงในท้องเนี่ย
ในท้องจะต้องมีไข่ทองคำอยู่เยอะแน่เลย
ใช่ไหมผู้ชายคิดนะคะคิดคิดผู้ชายคิดครู
ฝ้ายคิดไหมว่าในท้องห่านเนี่ยจะมีไข่ไข่
ไข่ไข่ไข่อีกหลายๆฟอง
ครูฟ้าว่า
ไม่มีนะ
จะมีได้ยังไงไข่ก็ต้องออกมาวันละ 1 ฟอง
เท่านั้นนี่ออกไข่วันละ 1 ฟองก็เยอะแล้ว
นะ
ใช่ๆ
แล้วนะคะผู้ชายคนนี้เนี่ยเขาก็เลย
เอาล่ะเขาอยากได้ไข่ทองคำมากขึ้นก็เลย
เดินเข้าไปในบ้านนะคะ
แล้วก็ไปหยิบนี่ค่ะ
อันนี้อะไร
เหมือนหรือเปล่า
เอาใหม่
ค่ะ
สเต็ก
ผู้ชายคนนี้ก็ไปหยิบมีดมาค่ะเรียม
หยิบมาทำไมคะ
ครูฟ้าหยิบมีดมาแล้วก็เดิน
มาหาห่านตัวนี้
แล้วก็
จับห่านมา
และใช้มีดเนี่ย
ผ่าท้อง 3 ค่ะ
[เพลง]
เป็นยังไงบ้างคะ
ห่านก็ตายทันทีเพราะว่านักเรียนฐานเนี่ย
โดนมีดใช่ไหมผ่าท้องนะคะผู้ชายเนี่ยหยิบ
มีดมาแล้วก็ผ่า
ท้องของห่าน
ห่านตายเลยนะคะตายเลยทันทีนึงแต่ว่า
ในท้องห่านเนี่ยไม่มีไข่ทองคำเลยไม่มี
อะไรเลย
แล้วที่ผู้ชายคิดคิดว่าในท้องห่านมีไข่
ทองคำ
ผู้ชายเนี่ยคิดผิดนะคะคิดผิด
[เพลง]
และไม่อ่านเนี่ยก็ตาย
ตายแล้วนะคะตายเลย
[เพลง]
เอาไข่ทองคำมาจากไหนคะ
ใช่สุดท้ายผู้ชายคนนี้ก็
ไม่มีไข่ทองคำอีกแล้วไม่มีผ่านไม่มีไข่
ทองคำ
ไม่มีอะไรเลยนะคะ
นอกจากเงินที่เก็บไว้
[เพลง]
แต่ก็ถ้าไม่ทำงานนะ
มีเงินที่เก็บไว้ก็จ่าย
จ่ายเงินจ่ายเงินวันนึงเงินก็ต้องหมด
ใช่วันหนึ่งเงินก็ต้องหมดไปก็เหลือ 0 ใช่
แล้วค่ะ
เราบอกว่าผู้ชายเนี่ยคิดอยากได้อยากได้
อยากได้อยากได้อยากได้อยากได้อยากได้
อยากได้มากๆก็เลย
ไม่มีอะไรเหลือเลยใช่ไหมว่าเราเราบอกว่า
มันไม่พอใช่ไหมถ้าเกิดเขามีเงินได้ขายทอง
คำ 1 วัน 1 ใบหรือว่า 1 ฟองแล้วก็เขาโอเค
แล้วเพราะว่ามันก็ได้เงิน
ทุกเขาก็อาจจะยังมีห่านแล้วก็มีไข่เนี่ย
เอาไปขายเอาไปขายเอาไปขายทุกวันก็ได้เงิน
ทุกวันแต่เพราะเขาอยากได้อยากได้อยากได้
มากขึ้นเนี่ยก็เลยค่าอาหารมันก็ไม่เหลือ
อะไรเลยไม่มีใครทองคำมากขึ้นและไม่มีห่าน
อีกแล้วเงินก็จะหมดเพราะว่ากินข้าวแล้วก็
ใช้เงินใช้เงินใช่ไหม 1 วันก็หมด
เรียมคิดว่า
ไข่ทองคำ
เอาไปขาย 1 ฟอง 1 ใบนะก็ได้เงิน
มากๆเลย
ไม่รู้เหมือนกันว่าทำไมผู้ชายคนนี้แบบไม่
โอเค
อยากได้อีกอยากได้อีกอยากได้เงินอยากได้
ทองคำ
ใช่ไหมไข่ทองคำนะคะห้าแล้วก็ประมาณนี้
เนาะเรียนวันนี้นิทานประมาณนี้นะคะเจอกัน
ใหม่คลิปหน้านะคะนักเรียนและนักเรียนก็รอ
ดูว่าครูฟ้าจะมีนิทานอะไรมาให้นักเรียน
ฟังอีกเนาะใช่ค่ะวันนี้ก็ต้องลาไปก่อนค่ะ
เพราะว่าเวลาหมดแล้วค่ะคุณฟ้าถ้าอย่าง
นั้นก็ไปก่อนนะคะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะ